with megan lying on the grass with her
head
in harry's lap they couldn't look
happier to share their news
with the world their spokesperson
confirming archie is going to be
a big brother the duke and duchess of
sussex are overjoyed to be expecting
their second child
whenever the sussex says say or do
anything particularly about their
family or their personal circumstances
there is a huge amount of attention and
we've seen an absolute explosion
of attention uh following this
announcement yeah so it is a different
uh feeling to
when other royal babies have been born
in the uk and family members we know
go and visit very soon as soon as
possible this royal baby
may not see some of his or her family
members for several months the rabbit is
hiding in the grass
as they've settled into their new life
in america it was clear they wanted to
expand their family
in november megan wrote about their
trauma at losing a child due to
miscarriage in the summer
saying they wanted to help end the taboo
around baby loss
the fact they're now no longer working
royals has allowed them to keep their
baby news quieter for longer
but we understand they had already told
the family the palace saying the queen
the duke of edinburgh the prince of
wales and the entire family
are delighted and wish them well we
always know that for the queen any
addition to her family brings her
enormous joy
she loves her children grandchildren and
great-grandchildren and that growing
clan that she has been the matriarch for
and remains so
is always the source of her greatest
pleasure and i think is a distraction to
her role as head of state
being kept informed of what's going on
amongst her family is very special
already we have seen how protective
they've been to try to keep
archie who will turn two in may out of
the public eye
and megan's victory in her case against
the male on sunday last week
again made it clear they will do
anything to defend the privacy of their
family
but when will we see the new arrival for
now
they're keeping that part of the happy
news to themselves